i don't think players on chess.com
should be allowed to resign early in the
game just because you took their queen
that really sounds uh misogynist i think
that anytime you lose your queen it's a
good time to get out of there
i think people want to torture their
food a little bit you know it's funny
sean i actually got that direct feedback
from someone who was a friend
and in this real-time conversation over
lunch it took me forever to realize
what he was complaining about was that
he was winning and people were resigning
and not letting him torture his opponent
and finish the job and i was like
[Music]
hey i'm danny chief chess officer here
at just.com and i'm sean director of
support hs.com
in this video we're going to dive into
the many messages that our community
members
send us within a given month which could
be hundreds of thousands of messages
from
reddit to twitter to youtube to direct
messages sent to support
where members might be giving
constructive and positive feedback
to maybe delivering on the little bit of
a darker side of a unique way to deliver
some criticism
complain about being closed for cheating
just some things like that
shian and i have not seen these
questions that are about to be presented
before us
but we're pretty pumped to dive in and
give you our honest feedback
as a couple of the guys working hard to
keep the chess community awesome here at
chess.com
so let's dive in that
i'll just use a different email and keep
on cheating hahaha
well you know in all seriousness uh you
know if that's what you want to get out
of life
then i i i hope you enjoy it you know we
do have things to stop re-registration
and we're gonna do our best but
uh you know knock yourself uh silly oh
man
in a lot of ways it's just job security
for me job security sean there you go
you have it right there
hello i would like the troll face emoji
on your website in as high definition as
possible
okay he wants the troll face i get
like as an avatar as as a as a i i mean
okay
i don't really know that that's not okay
that is a meta troll question right
there that is a
that is like i feel like i was being
trolled in the middle of that
question and it still and i still don't
get it
hello chess.com support my name is
magnus carlson i was playing on a smurf
account having fun trying to teach my
prodigy
after playing a friend we embarked on a
chess battle to the death
however i seem to have decimated him too
bad as he rage quit the game and
reported me please unban my prodigies
account at once before i denounce
chess.com
go to leachat like all other pros thank
you for your time
i'm deeply upset that my prodigies
account was banned in the first place
please rectify the mistake
and all will be well and uh the
follow-up message
sean it has been about two years since
you've banned my prodigy
all i have to say now is that maggie is
mad
watch the next tournament where i'll be
dropping the hottest rose session of all
time about you
i will run out my clock by roasting the
living
out of you and then checkmating my
opponent the last second however my
offer is still on the table
see to it that my prodigies account is
unbanned at once
and compensate with two years of premium
for last time so we can go out to dinner
with each other after you come watch my
next tournament
i love this i mean
the thing is is that we are this is not
a new strategy
people write in pretending to be super
gm's all the time
my favorite one was a guy who wrote in
pretending to be fab
fabi and he uh actually misspelled
fabby's name
so uh what what an interesting try i i
really like that
and um you know kudos to him for writing
and maggie is mad i like that i like
that
i am not using any support engine when
i'm playing nor
asking for advice from other chess
player i just move
on my own your system regulation
uh so fun fact for this particular
username um i've actually got his report
up right here and
uh that is not the case sir you have
been using illegal assistance
and you've been caught for performance
enhancing chess engine use
so d9
millions of support cases incoming i'm
funding people in india to flood the
out of your support system you for the
next year you'll be picking bulls
queries up and not be able to tell bull
from actual customer inquiry it's going
to be great fun
go yourselves now
well this is the weirdest thing right
people are writing into support
and they're like hey we're gonna make it
so that your department is bigger
i'm gonna i'm gonna play on your site so
much you have to get
more server space i'm gonna
job security as they say every time you
read a message like that that was um
that was that was a hall of fame rant
right there loved it
a good man out of the good treasure of
the heart bringeth forth good things
and an evil man out of the evil treasure
bringeth forth evil things
but i say unto you
that every idle word that men shall
speak they shall give account thereof in
the day of judgment
for by thy words thou shalt be justified
and by thy words thou shalt be condemned
hi there thank you for your kind reply
and for taking weeks to fix your issue
i'm sure you'll blame the issue
and the long lack of comprehension at my
feet and not yours yeah we probably will
um it's sad to read that you attacked my
friend's account with an error then
attacked her account by
opening it and giving her a second
chance and then lastly attacked her
account by ultimately closing it
and blaming the whole thing at my feet i
don't think we usually blame jesus for
stuff questions
how do you take account for your attacks
on her chess.com account
and who is going to pay for those
attacks i can answer that question right
now
um we account for it by saying that we
close all fair play accounts and who's
going to pay for it clearly the person
whose account was changed
uh was closed you can say i violated
some policy but what policy did you
violate while i played some games on her
account
waiting weeks on you to fix a simple
issue with my account
you can't plan someone else's account by
definition
getting outside assistance um conclusion
to this email
you contact my friend at her email
address you address each of those
attacks on our chess.com account for
whatever reason each attack
you want to solve this issue with her if
you don't for whatever reason then this
email is my request for you to close my
chest.com account
for good i appreciate you finally
correcting the issues with my account
but
how evil and rude of you to attack my
friend's account three times
and then you throw salt in the wounds by
not saying a word to her
and a communication you basically stuck
a knife in her back three times and ran
away
and blamed me for it thank you thanks
and god bless you
in christ jesus of nazareth
[Laughter]
um let's just say
he will be missed that's true
recently i have had four incidents where
i have moved a pawn
up two squares from its starting
position and it shows as such if i go
back one move
using the arrows only for it to be taken
as if i had only moved it up
one square so the game history will show
the pawn on the square two up
for example a7 to a5 but in the actual
game play
it will be taken as if i had moved it to
a6
this is usually in the end game where
pawn to queen promotion is at stake
it's a glitch and is annoying the part
of me as i'm losing close games because
of this bug
look i know what it's total honesty here
every chess player can remember when
they learned that rule
so no one should feel bad we get
two of these in support per day at least
i was just gonna you get two per day on
testing
at least probably every 50 to 100
tickets there's going to be an on
poisson in there well can can i then
jump in and say and you're the you lead
the team with support
in my right and saying the best part
about this ticket is he actually goes
into some detail right and actually
talks about check
the game history i mean we get we get
ones that are literally
like fu fix this bug or i'm not coming
back right so am i right to say that
kudos to that member for going into the
painstaking detail
of just how much pawn promotion is
indeed at stake yeah
i don't want anyone to feel bad my one
my one
angry point here is that in queens
gambit they did not explain that move
i feel like if they had done that they
would save us hours of work
true sure i don't think players on
chess.com should be allowed to resign
early in the game just because you took
their queen
that really sounds uh misogynist i think
that anytime you lose your queen it's a
good time to get out of there
i think people want to torture their
food a little bit you know it's funny
sean i actually got that direct feedback
from someone who was a friend
and in this real-time conversation over
lunch it took me forever to realize
what he was complaining about was that
he was winning and people were resigning
and not letting him
torture his opponent and finish the job
and i was like
you know you want to feel it you want to
feel that superiority you want it to
last for many moves yeah
the answer is no we're not going to
prevent people from resigning okay next
question
anybody stall when they know they've
lost in hopes other person resigns
that's awesome i
i think you know uh so you're saying
there's a chance you know optimism
springs eternal
in the hearty soul of humankind um but i
will
never if it is a 30 minute game
and i've got you beat at 29 30.
i am gonna wait those 29 minutes and 30
seconds
i'll jump in on that one sean and say
that one that's awesome that we have a
member
like outing himself as part of the
problem right the amount of complaints
we get on the other side of like i'm
winning
and my opponent is literally letting his
clock run out
i'm gonna say screw that guy for outing
himself as part of the problem literally
saying i
purposely stall to torture my opponent
when they're beating me
and then he's mad when they resign right
frustrating
hellochess.com staff when i bend the
knee and ask you for forgiveness to open
a new account will be the day i will
climb to a high tower and jump headfirst
you have failed the task of preventing
cheaters from taking my hard-earned
rating
thus forcing me to take measures into my
own hands
to think i was paying chess.com for
premium services makes my skin crawl
over the years i've provided you with
endless proofs that my opponents were
cheating and you ignored them
but the last game before my account was
closed was a loss to a 1560 rating
player when i was 1966 rating
that was the straw that broke the
camel's back i wish chess.com to be
hacked by
chinese hackers and completely deleted
so you can understand how frustrating it
is to face cheaters i'd wish you a happy
day but that would be a lie
go yourselves cheers
that's so good
oh man it looks so good specifies the
ethnicity of the hackers
it can't be colombian hackers it can't
be russian hackers it's gotta be chinese
we have been hacked by hackers uh of all
different types of nationalities in race
and so
you know um anyway responding to that is
so awesome
i think uh uh i'll refer to something my
dad once said
as a kid which is those who are who are
most paranoid
we all have fears from time but those
who typically are most paranoid in life
that they're being taken advantage of
are usually the people taking advantage
of someone
we're doing our best continuing to close
cheaters um by the tens of thousands as
we do and you know cheat reports
i talk about in my state of chess.com
all the time i feel pretty good about
what we're doing
and i'm very sorry but i will say please
don't actually jump off any roofs
at any time and i if i could i want to
jump in here and give a little bit of
self-help advice
when you are thinking that your opponent
is cheating
you are looking at their moves and
you're looking at the strengths of their
moves
and what you need to be doing when
you're playing chess is looking at the
weakness
in their moves so if you are paranoid
your opponent is cheating it is going to
affect your
your performance it's happened to me
it's kind of a dark spiral then you get
frustrated and that hurts your play as
well
so just know that less than one percent
far less than one percent of the games
on our site actually have
additional outside assistance in them so
uh when you're playing just keep your
eyes open
look for that mistake for your opponent
and you will be rewarded
look at that wink wink so we can do that
that's great advice what does my 293
points mean
do i get a free toaster 293 points for
what your rating
or or did you gain that in puzzles like
i mean
that's great no matter how good your
rating is 293 points is a lot of points
that's good
um no free coasters though
that's not we're not we're not in that
business so um just thanks for playing
can we get penny to give him a free
digital poster
like our toaster right now
let's pop that up here
what if i referred you to my friend
benjamin franklin
the rule i broke was because i
misinterpreted the fair play policies
i thought it said players are allowed to
use opening books in the live
game which is what i did but after
review it was only for correspondence
i'm sure you can understand this honest
mistake
i i love both that he thinks that you
can bribe us
and that he thinks the that he could
bribe us with just a hundred dollars i
mean these these are very bad thoughts
um but i i love that uh i love the spunk
i
love the uh the hutzpah i love that he's
really putting it out there
um but uh now he's gonna need some new
friends
that's that's so awesome because he just
confessed which
is all we actually require of someone to
come back is be honest about it and
and most people do so he actually
confessed but he started out with
what at least i was like what if i refer
you to my friend george washington
that would have been much better i would
have taken that one right away
hey i hope you get cancer you stupid
i got banned for literally talking trash
to my opponents
two hours later
well first uh many props our streams are
are absolutely great uh
love them secondly i think we can tell
from the email that he didn't get banned
for saying
a single bad word
so i don't think that's the case but no
not
to take a serious slant on this you know
when you're talking to someone face to
face there's a lot of social cues you
can pick up trash talk can be viewed as
kind of funny
but over the internet when you're
dealing with with just a mass of
different cultures
a lot of times your trash talk may not
may not be taken in the manner in which
it was intended
um and and that uh does mean that we ask
people to be nice
and uh the good thing is that if you're
friends with someone you're free to uh
the trash talk on their site so if
that's your thing you can do it but make
sure you friend them first and the
person is
is down with that kind of thing
no other no other comments that thank
you thank you for sharing
that message that's all i'm going to say
i needed a good laugh
hello i got a warning from chess.com and
my account got muted
because apparently i have violated the
community guidelines
may i ask why because i did not behave
in an inappropriate way at any time
i once had a fight with a guy that
insulted me but since then i behaved
exemplary
so why did i get a warning i didn't do
anything wrong
well i'm just gonna guess from the
message that it might have been that
fight that you had
um but we do have uh auto moderators
and uh that will just pick out certain
phrases and give you a warning if you
hit that phrase
and uh sometimes it can be on accident
like one time i was writing about it and
i put the space in the wrong place and
then i got hit for it
uh so these things can happen sometimes
just write your friendly neighborhood
support agent
we'll go through the auto log and we'll
help you out i don't want to ask you to
explain what about it became when you
hit space at the wrong place
i'm going to use my imagination for that
and move on
continually came out repeatedly and
always took the same time to execute the
movement
no matter how complex the position
i don't even i don't even know what to
say to that sean why don't you take that
one
we we often get requests for other chess
websites
um and it's just uh we have to let them
know that hey
we're not this company you know we're
chess.com and uh
that's the thing about being a very
large uh
you know public-facing companies that
people think that you're everywhere
hi i learned that fide is making a major
change in rules by which stalemate will
be deemed to be a victory to the side
with advantage
do you plan to incorporate this in your
app i guess now is the time to say
april fools yeah exactly there you go
we have actually talked about this on a
regular basis
as crazy as that idea seems one of the
things that makes chess
hard to relate to for the
non-traditional audience is the draw
and so i'm actually gonna say that that
idea is not it's not the
worst idea um that um that maybe um
chess players and fans have ever come up
with uh that said i
we do not have any plans to incorporate
that at this time i think it's more
philosophical in terms of
where it's at in the pipeline of a
debate leading to an actual feature
so we'll leave it at that but not the
work not the worst idea in the world as
far as i'm concerned
why doesn't chess.com show which game
was the cheetah
am i expected to through thousands of
games looking for the cheetah
okay that's actually so that's
that's good that's a good question and
good feedback i will say this because we
are now
rewarding points back after you if you
lost games to cheaters
it's not that hard for you to do your
own
investigation right and put on your
sherlock holmes hat
and dive into figuring out where and how
you you got your points back from and in
fact
if you visit the profiles of the players
you played you might even see that they
were closed for cheating yeah we want to
make sure that everyone knows that
they're
safe and that if there's cheating that
they're uh the justice will be served
and they'll get their points back and
that
all is evened out at the end but we
definitely don't want to go out to the
villagers and hand them pitchforks and
touch it
and say you know let's go grab the
pitchforks and go get this guy right now
it kind of happens but you got to do
that on your own time we're not going to
be uh starting the mob thank you for
your email
i would like to appeal the ruling
because i know i am completely innocent
i was under 15 chess champions many
years ago if that helps
i haven't played on this website for
some time and when i did play
most of the time i played against my
work colleague
so i have no idea as to how i can be
accused of
unfair play i have never engaged in any
of the practices mentioned in your links
so fun fact this appeal was actually
granted and this particular member is
currently
an active diamond member uh premium
paying customer on the site and so upon
further review there was actually
a mistake in this one so i guess here
we're just saying that
a respectful appeal and actually there
was uh this was uh
likely a human mistake and
misinterpreting the data more than
anything else but
as far as we know this username is
actually back on our site and an active
diamond member as of today so
well done sir good appeal does
climbingchess.com leaderboard have any
benefits
does having a high rank in chess.com
have benefit of any sort
either in-game features or similar or
even something like
internship read they hire people to
check for anti-cheating
claiming leaderboards has benefits of it
is its own reward am i allowed to say
that does that sound like a dad in me
like you know doing your best is your
best
we do not hire or look for talent based
on the leaderboards
when looking to to add to the team
however there are
often opportunities to apply for a job
at chess.com jobs
and you know it's a streaming world so
you're climbing a leaderboard there's a
lot of uh
street cred that you get you know
showing that on your streams yeah
so uh what i want you to think about
when you're writing into support you
know be as clear as possible
um our guys are professionals you know
we pay them well they do this as a job
and the one thing that i ask is that you
treat them with a modicum of that
professionality you know we're a gaming
website so it's going to be a lot of fun
but imagine saying what you typed out
loud
in like a grocery store or a place of
business or in a restaurant
and if that would get you kicked out of
that place of business
don't type it you know take a moment
pause breathe
write it again it's fine for you to vent
your frustration but don't do it
at my people i'm very protective i love
them a lot i think that's a great
a great just sort of rule of thumb is if
you wouldn't actually say this
face to face to someone or in front of
children or in another public place of
business
probably you shouldn't say it even if
you are upset about whatever whatever's
going down online so
anyway this was a lot of fun obviously
we hope you enjoyed it um
and uh leave a comment down below be
kind right
rewind watch it again hit the subscribe
and uh we will uh we'll see you around
on chess.com hopefully reading uh some
more positive messages from here on out
uh this was a message sent in to us from
a young uh man young child 11 years old
who was closed for cheating
uh we found out this account had been
closed not just once but
twice for cheating on our site and had
actually been closed on leeches as well
and his message to support was very very
clear
uh to go yourself the funny thing about
this one is that this was then later
uh appealed to us by the parents uh and
and of course their their little angel
could not cheat
and one of the things we provided along
with the evidence we could
uh was also the threat of emails from
their from their
child uh to support so that was um that
was a very fun interaction
if you're a parent you know you've
played candy land with that child
you've seen them cheat you've seen them
roll a seven and then end up on free
parking
you've watched this happen in real time
how are you thinking that they're an
angel and i i just don't get pink so we
can do that
ding that was great advice or we get a
more you know
this public service announcement brought
to you by all right let's go
the jacket's kind of bunching a little
bit you might want to kind of pull it
down a little bit yep
cool okay okay um
this next one for sean and i this is for
the outtakes
hey margarita
[Music]
you